good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast we made it through the
weekend for some reason this whole thing
gave me really more ominous vibes on a
Friday but now it's Monday like the
streets are somewhat you know active
it's making me feel less doomsday vibe
oh no I feel like we saw it Friday with
something and it was nothing of the sort
and today being mundane it's like the
start of a whole new week a whole new
like landscape I feel like we're coming
back to a whole different show oh yeah
something about like I that we are
overreacting as a precautionary and
ounce of prevention is a pound of
carrion and that makes me feel really
good that everyone's really taking those
types of steps but something about it
being Friday just made me feel like
Monday was not ever gonna happen but now
it's Monday and psych we made it through
the weekend the quarantine wasn't bad I
had enough food you know my whole
concern has been like where I'm gonna
get my next meal and it was well fed the
whole weekend clearly my face is puffier
than ever and I feel good about that
yeah I hear what you're saying you know
I do not leave my house from the time
you last saw me on the show went home
stayed home and now I'm back like I
definitely look like a little like green
I left once greeny vibe I didn't walk
feel at all I love having higher that I
heard that you did leave ones yeah just
don't judge me for it like I just had to
get out I'm not gonna judge you because
and then what you are I got you a ten
person game night as long as you were
practicing social distancing I gene
that's all we can really ask for I went
to a game night I played code names
again same group of people so like I
think I think I'm safe yeah like you
would have already gotten it from these
because they came to my house on
Thursday if you hadn't already our
husbands are still playing Monopoly oh
my god in there leo annoying I made my
husband wear latex gloves to play with
thee fools I saw and I told men no more
really because you know what like I'm
all for people having recreational you
know activities but it's like this is
it's the same reason I hate when bed and
plays golf because he leaves me alone
the whole day Ben went to go play
Monopoly with your sack 4:30 he don't
get home till 10:00 yeah but he also
went grocery shopping I don't care ya
know for me it's like you need that
distance I feel like this quarantine is
gonna put a lot of marriages to the test
I think a lot of babies are gonna get me
the quarantine zwi r going
call them yep that's next-gen oh it's
just gonna be it's gonna be super
telling so I just felt like the weekend
I was kind of like nervous about staying
home it ended up being totally fine they
saw a lot of people's self quarantine
and good for you but I also saw a lot of
people and I'm not gonna judge people
who went out this weekend because maybe
they didn't know how serious it was and
also like it's not mandatory to not go
out but you know what really [ __ ]
bothering me this weekend people who
were like out or at bars or at brunch
being like social distancing oh you know
saying social distancing is six feet of
partying or sitting shoulder to shoulder
yeah so like it's just like do you
realize that you're not social
distancing do you realize that you know
those people are [ __ ] but like I
really hope that an overwhelming
percentage of the people like did take a
step back and social distance but I did
see that there were like people out and
about and as much as it annoyed me it
made me like a little happy that these
local businesses were still having
people like I think that like 90 percent
of the world should stay home but ten
percent should just go out to their
local bars local restaurants local nail
places just to make sure even if you're
not gonna like get your now so I'm like
buy a gift card like just I don't know
it's just really scaring me that like
people are losing their jobs there's no
there's no plan in place like when is
this gonna unhappen like when every
place is gonna open again and I saw over
the weekend like I'm at Bastion the CEO
of Delta decided to forgo his salary for
six months to keep employees being paid
which is like crazy like one man in six
months makes what an entire company
makes in six months whatever but it's
like it's even if okay so it's affecting
Delta imagine how it's affecting the
deli yeah you know so I just think like
when you can like III did take an uber
and it left a 25% tip that's as much as
I'll let you leave like I just think in
little ways you you can and should
support local businesses while also
being conscious of social distancing cuz
that is the priority here but it's like
I still saw people out and it didn't
know me but also I'm like you know I'm
glad like this bar is good business
world isn't just completely shutting
down yeah so it's Jay home but if you do
if you do need to eat while bars and
restaurants are still out like order
delivery they're taking precaution I
hope that restaurants don't have to stop
doing takeout like cuz I think that that
will be a whole other level of black out
yeah craziness well so - in New York the
mayor announced last night that starting
Tuesday all bars and restaurants are
mandatory to be closed but they can't do
takeout and delivery right which is good
it's not great but it's it's okay I'm
hoping that the sooner we do all of this
the sooner we can
and overcome this and get back to normal
life because it really it's a must it's
so stressful like I don't want to end up
like Italy and Friday I was really
worried about the health concerns and I
think today I'm really worried just
about people's livelihoods and you know
how are people gonna pay their rent and
how do we bounce back from this
yeah like when do we just decide I think
once the case once the day comes where
the new cases are going down instead of
going up we can maybe start to resume in
life but in the meantime just make sure
you're staying clean washing your hands
being aware of your surroundings
don't do anything extra touch your for
chairman I think the fact whose
birthdays are coming up like Ben's
birthday and he's like such a birthday
baby
he we had this whole trip planned to
Vegas which we're obviously not gonna go
anymore and he's like so concerned about
his birthday because now the CDC
recommends canceling any events with 50
people or more so Mike Ben where might
just have to have it like a game night
for your birthday oh that would be he
would actually love that yeah but like
he's such a good Queen on his birthday
you know he's out of control good to be
knocked down if he already felt like us
going to Vegas was like not gonna be
enough because we wanted to go to like
Kelly Clarkson he's a really big
birthday Queen and so that's what he
gets yeah watching it Heather McMahon's
story it was her birthday yesterday she
literally sat in her apartment all day
wow it's so crazy so glad I'm summer
baby hopefully this will not be a
problem by my birthday hopefully oh my
gosh if we're still in this situation
I'm like I'm taking this quarantine so
seriously I'm eating burnt grilled
cheeses cuz apparently I don't even know
how to make a [ __ ] grilled cheese I
mean if the summer is still like
quarantine vibes my hands are literally
gonna fall off they're so crusty and
drive from watching them so much and I
haven't got a manicure my nails will be
in the healthiest shape they've ever
been that's true I've had a manicure
straight for like ten years
do you feel like the quarantine has been
good for the skin aside from the lack of
like vitamin C and D make sure you're
taking your supplements um it's good to
like not wear makeup you know I've been
seeing a lot of people doing wearing
wearing face masks yes I do the mask
over the weekend it took like six baths
it's great but like eventually I'm just
gonna shrivel up from the bath and it's
like it's annoying ya know the best part
of my days right now is the time when I
take a shower cuz it feels like I'm
doing like I'm going somewhere and it's
like different yeah that's a different
state it's liquid ya know it's it's
quite a big wash I even I wash my hair
both nights Wow I just like was happy to
be in the shower I mean I watched so
much TV and we've added a segment to
this show since there's limited news to
talk about and we don't really want to
talk about coronavirus the whole time
we're gonna try and find like mindless
celebrity stories for you guys but even
the mindless celebrities like are about
coronavirus but we've decided to add a
segment at the end of the show where
we're gonna recap everything we've been
watching like over the weekend I watch a
million movies caught up at a million TV
shows we will recap at all and then very
excitingly to announce wanna by popular
demand we're gonna bring back toasts
movie of the week but it's gonna be
toast movie of the day because we're
going live every day this week and
there's really nothing to do other than
watch TV so we're gonna assign a movie
every day and we will recap it the next
day so we'll give the assignment at the
end of the episode feel free to join us
if you're if you're working from home
you're a little bored you need something
to watch join us toast movie of the week
club but toys movie of the day and that
way we have things to talk about that
aren't so doomsday yeah I don't really
want to talk about coronavirus like that
much even though what else is there and
it's like there's nothing else that no
one's that people are talking about
there's nothing else that I'm thinking
about like every waking minute of my day
I am thinking about coronavirus oh
you're not I'm not I'm just really
thinking about like will I run out of
food that is mine whenever that's
directly related to coronavirus oh yeah
I am thinking about the corn Steve I
know I'm not really thinking about like
the virus itself like in like I'm taking
the proper precautions I'm just so
worried about like civilization and the
economy and food like I can't stress
that enough and I know I've said this a
million times but we do have four
thousand people watching a latte and
like I don't have a stove there's like
this problem in my building with the gas
so um I was limited in what I could
purchase at the store I don't have an
oven either but I did order a hot plate
on Amazon like I'm ready for my trailer
park and it arrives today so we'll be
able to boil pasta which is very
exciting for me but like I know but it's
like how much weight am I gonna gain oh
my god you guys I've been eating like
crazy terrible like frozen pizza pasta
sandwiches how many crafts I mean if
you're gonna if you're I'm not much of a
stocks woman but if you're gonna invest
invest in Kraft because I have to
imagine everyone is buying Kraft Mac and
Cheese its microwavable Susie its
non-perishable well now we have like
frapped
frack and cheese oh yeah because you got
what was left behind you got any it's no
no no it's like even more orange Leslie
Mac the ramen noodles Oh Kraft Mac and
Ramon is also a great investment that's
true that's true
oh my god I mean what what Ben got from
the grocery store like I sent him out we
had been buying like I bought bagels and
froze them I didn't really take it so
seriously but then when they announced
that restaurants and bars we're gonna
close I'm like damn I need a fully
stocked house
so sent back to the grocery store I said
non-perishables what does he come back
with Satsuki a yogurt based Greek dip
LOX
yes salmon those go to bed at 12 hours
Oh shopping with my husband because he
came back there were probably only
certain things up because he came out
with the same brand of Sam
oh did Ben come back with a pre-made
grilled chicken Caesar salad like what
the [ __ ] that is perishable no he did
get canned green beans but meaning not
by one thing in a can but we don't have
a can opener but we don't have a can
opener like the major case of an
emergency you could like saw it open
throw it at the wall yeah get mad at
your husband you throw it at him yeah my
windbreaker is like making such a lot of
noise because it's breaking wind as I
break wind and I'm sorry for the
podcasters but so many people are
watching live today which is just it's
the place to be so funny we were talking
like a couple weeks ago about how like
we wondered if we'd ever farted on the
toast and I guess like we had but we
just like hadn't thought about it
because now since then I farted like a
million times like I literally just
farted now and I I think about it every
time because we've now spoken about it
Oh interesting you should get like
smellivision for the podcast thank you
for sharing that well that you know if
it reaches me but maybe all those fart
chairman's
yeah and feels really taking this
quarantine seriously I mean he goes out
with his mask and his gloves
he knows that dogs can't carry it but he
just wants to be extra safe and he
doesn't want to be a puppy vector
because I have to believe that if
someone who has kernel pets him and then
you pet him like you could get it right
I don't think so
really does it on stay on the fur I
don't think so how can they tell me that
my coat can hold it for up to 5 days but
what about Theo he's a fur coat that's
the thing there's so much misinformation
being spread and there's certain people
who like I trust if you follow Simon
Hawk on Instagram like he is really just
being so cautious about what he posts
because him and his company Judy there
an emergency prepared like so he is very
much trying not to spread misinformation
trying to instill like a sense of calm
and people but I feel like I don't want
to spread misinformation like I haven't
really been posting corona related stuff
because everything is fake like I even
the CDC I'm like are you sure I'm just
not sure about what's being put out
there so I'm not trying to spread any
misinformation I'm just trying to like
be funny like post good content that's
what people need I mean my numbers my
story of use have never been higher but
I'm just trying to like be funny and not
spread misinformation or cause panic yes
I think that is very
but there is one cause that I think
everyone should talk about and I've been
seeing a lot of celebrities getting
involved it's making me really happy
because sadly they had to shut down you
know the schools even though like I so
wish I was in school right now like just
high school like this would wrong like I
have nothing to lose like it's just like
winter break forever but the sad thing
about that ring break forever right
right the sad thing about that is that
like in New York specifically there's
over 150,000 homeless kids who rely on
like lunch at school like to be their
only meal throughout the day so there's
programs like feeding America and
everyone should look into it cuz like
that's really sad yeah and even for
people who are still working and they
don't have childcare and their kids are
home from school it's really complicated
but I did I actually had a pretty good
idea if anyone in the government is
listening I think that for kids who need
to be looked after they should go to
school and the kids who are home from
college should look after them at the
schools because they are all pretty low
risk for coronavirus so like you know
those kids should step up and watch the
kids
ya know I think that's a great idea like
the classic case of cameras and
counselors right we need that's what the
CDC needs to see this is in charge you
need to hire a bunch of counselors to
protect the campers that's what I'm
saying and campers to protect the
counselors because don't forget the
campers are our future
they are the campers are a future let
them lead the way
bye they like people in the comments
going off I was obviously kidding the
CDC's in charge like everything they say
is right it was a joke and I just think
now more than ever people need to really
like lay off on the joke criticism
because it was a [ __ ] joke okay I
just want to say if you're if you're
coming to the show looking for us to say
all the right things go so are like CNN
and like the news are there people like
all 24 hours a day are they working
actually this morning I went to watch
some news just to see what other people
were talking about and there was no E
news this morning live with Kelly and
Ryan was a old episode with John
Krasinski good day New York was on they
had a segment where a woman showed how
you can make fun things with the items
around your house I guess it was pretty
good that is so out of touch observer
but it sounds pretty good if you don't
have chips but you have tortillas oh
right like you literally just kind of a
tortilla and you put it in the soil and
that's a drip and then you make a chip I
got I thought it was like a nice you
know they obviously need to think of
segments yeah but so a lot of
entertainment program programming is off
but I do think a lot of the news
programming is on okay including the
morning toast we
Heymann and news program it's a low risk
program because like nobody works here
and we live like in our studios we lived
within walking distance and there's
three of us in this video so we are
practicing social distancing but I think
for a big show you there's definitely
more than 50 people on set and the CDC
would say yeah and they're all of a
certain age this is a millennial show so
it's the Millennial morning everyone
here is like 25 results so yes and if
you are a millennial in your area you
should maybe see if you can babysit some
kids while their parents have to go to
work I was thinking of like taking up
some activities because I do think that
like staying home and watching TV while
my husband is in the house like I
actually might shoot him so his thing is
taking up time I just complain that he
was gone for too long oh by the way that
is Mike Ross Tamara do you not know that
like I literally hate being alone but I
hate being around bad like it's
literally it's them and he's so confused
by it because yesterday yesterday he was
annoying me so much like go play
Monopoly then he go tell him at 10 I'm
like really 10 o'clock you don't spend
time with me I'm the most annoying
person to be married to but I struggle
between like not wanting to be alone but
also not wanting to be coddled and like
smothered by then so this will be a
really interesting week so I'm singing
maybe ordering some coloring books up
Amazon like I'm just I I first see
myself being bored maybe I'll get back
into knitting oh that's good I was I
used to be quite the knitter I made
myself a scarf once I've been reading a
lot which is a good break from watching
TV because it you're pretty much binging
in the same way but it's better for your
brain I'm so I'm going to share some
book recommendations right after this
but it's funny oh all we talk about is
how we just like want to watch TV and
lay in bed all day it's not all that
detail and now everyone has the
opportunity to do it unlimitedly and
we're like I miss fresh air yeah no I
don't miss fresher
um at all okay you know what else is a
real bummer like this really is like the
best time of year like this week right
before I swing right before it's allergy
season but the weather's nice the days
are long like obviously you just want a
crisp Sancerre
al fresco yeah and that's just not
happening it would be easier to stay
inside when it was like gross outside
but now it's like we then freeze I would
love to feel it between my thighs like
like not even like it's in the middle of
summer me and it's a nice day we have to
stay home like this was our first taste
yes--why boots like this they don't
happen very often look outside you guys
the sun is shining like this never
happens in New York is it so Thomas is
where like you want to like sit outside
and
to Central Park sitting on my bed I
literally was in bed the whole weekend I
didn't even simply move on the couch and
I was just looking out the window the
whole weekend just at the beauty it was
couldn't a bit we couldn't have asked
for a nicer weekend to be quarantined
I'm spending so much time in my bed and
I'm really realizing how I don't like my
mattress and it's really tough for me
because it's a tough time to figure that
out I chipped out when I bought my
mattress like I just like went on
Memorial Day weekend I got a sale won a
mattress firm and it's just nothing of
the sort it's so lumpy now and I just
don't know what to do about it I can't
flip it because it's not that type of
mattress and I'm thinking maybe Amazon
is gonna be my best bet maybe like a
mattress top like it needs to firm up my
back is literally like a crate
yeah maybe that's all start there yeah I
actually um was just hanging in a
friend's house and the bed was amazing
and I was like what is this you know
like ducks Anna
it was IKEA mattress Wow yeah it was
phenomenal maybe I'll look into that I
have a great mattress so a good mattress
is the key to a happy life and a happy
marriage and a happy quarantine yeah and
like a happy wrinkle on your forehead
cause like you're not gonna be frowning
all day because you're tired totally
well are you ready to get into the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast that you probably
burn if you're me
I am ready anything very appropriately
because a lot of us are worried about
you know the the Freshman Fifteen when
it comes to quarantine the freshman
quarantine today's episode is brought to
you by noon getting in shape doesn't
have to be about losing a specific
amount of weight or a magic number on
the scale it's about building healthier
habits and feeling better about yourself
if fitting into that favorite pair of
jeans is your goal great but there are
many reasons why you might want to
practice self-care and every person is
different and because we're all
different Numa just to your lifestyle
they teach you the psychology behind the
decisions you make and they help you
keep track of everything from workouts
and steps to analyzing your diet and
recommending healthy recipes Numazu
connects you with personally assigned
goal specialists and a community of
other numers so you have all the support
you need to empower your change I feel
like before coronavirus everyone was
talking about how it's like the time to
get in shape because like summers around
the corner but now that we have all this
free time it's now more pertinent than
ever there's so many reasons why you
could want to take better care of
yourself whether it's self-care feeling
confident and clothing more energy
having an overall glow new is great
because you can integrate it into your
life you trust yourself to make good
choices
Noom is the habit
a solution that helps users learn to
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses Noom is not
a diet it's a healthy and easy to stick
to way of life no food is good batter
off-limits Noom teaches you moderation
and can be used in conjunction with many
pre-existing diets if you want
they've one of the most biggest and
accurate food databases that lets you
track your meal habits visualize portion
sizes and see calorie density at a
glance we're all strapped for time
neumes just asks you to commit to 10
minutes a day for yourself
chat with call specialists and community
to get and give help to people going
through the same thing you don't have to
change it all in one day small steps
make big progress sign up for your trial
at noon calm /host that's n oom dot-com
/ toast what do you have to lose visit
new calm / toast to start your trial
today n oom dot-com / toast what do you
have to lose noon is very pertinent to
the situation right now because it's
very easy to let yourself go in these
current of times all of our sponsors
today are just so incredibly pertinent
and that's because most of our sponsors
are things you could do at home oh well
they always have and they always will be
because it's the show right and that's
why the morning toast is and remains to
me one of the most relevant outlets on
television totally ok are you ready for
our first story Wow
it feels like we've been sitting for 35
minutes my pants are soiled I'm ready
first up Hannah brown travels to Florida
to see Tyler Cameron for a second time I
saw this breaking news on the satchel I
saw this breaking news on the Snatcher
she is the go-to place for all things
happening in bachelor nation right now
and a lot of things are weirdly
happening we reported last week that
Hannah brown went down to Jupiter
during Tyler's time of need but now
she's showing up to the airport with her
Louboutin on the ghost bag excuse me I
noticed that as well I had that purse I
wore today yep and Tyler Cameron is
loading her things into his car but like
he has something huge in the trunk and
so he came to put it in the backseat he
put it in backseat like what the [ __ ] is
in his trunk I don't know and by the way
there's nothing that annoys me more than
when people like come to pick you up
when you have a lot of stuff and they
come with a full trunk it's my biggest
pet peeve and it's my husband to a tee
literally years ago I had so many
examples years ago when Marga was moving
out of her dorm bed it's like the only
person we know in the city with a car so
Margot was like will you help me move
out like just fill up the car sure
Margot has like bedding clothes
furniture
Ben comes Larry with a full trunk I'm
like what the [ __ ] are you doing here
like we would have called an uber it's
the most annoying thing it happens all
the time it's because everyone in Ben's
family uses the car like for
everyone like his sister today pack her
to school it's always it's literally
like their home it's their everything so
it's always full and it drives me
[ __ ] nuts like he'll show up pick us
up from the airport he's like oh I'll
pick up a normal family from the airport
great comes we can't fit any of our
suitcases
it's so funny that you notice that
because I noticed it too he had to put
her suitcase in the back seat yeah and
it looks like a really big apparatus in
the trunk and it's like what did he
forget that he had had that in his trunk
and it's just it's the little details
about celebrities that make me so you
know interested he drives a Nissan right
that's like such a cute a cute car but
also like what the hell are they doing
together
I don't know weeks in a row like that's
more than friendship she's posting out
from Jupiter with Tyler's friend Matt
who didn't go on Claire season even
though they postponed her season here -
ready backed out before that was a true
yeah he's that's what I heard
I'm not sure maybe um that he didn't
wind up coming on Claire season that's
weird
uh-huh but also Claire season like his
postpone so who I know it's like Claire
Claire's like just that girl who can't
catch a break
gotcha Claire that is so true she's such
a Claire but to me she's like the girl
who can't catch a break and they're
really positioning her I was like the
girl who never gave up on love because
she's like almost 40 she will fight
coronavirus no but it's up now she's
getting the opportunity it's like that
girl she she really couldn't find love
she's almost 40 she finally gets his
majority and there's like this pandemic
outbreak that was now stopping her from
achieving her dreams of finding love
it's like she's she's the girl who can't
catch a break no but like once this all
dies down and she does go on her journey
I feel like that narrative will be even
bigger like she won't will she love the
coronavirus couldn't stop her and
neither will you
she's just like it's she's such a Clair
that was so perfectly said um but that's
weird I didn't know that he's not going
on now yeah but or who knows but Tyler
and Hannah be do we think that they are
I mean romantically involved I see it
from a lot of angles I could see it as
like she's really just being there for
him in his time of need because he is
going through this grieving process with
his mom but the timing is really
interesting because people are really
being encouraged not to travel and
here's Hannah Brown like putting her
life on the line and they feel like
you're only gonna put your life on the
line to travel to Jupiter like for
someone you're in love with not for
someone you're like take you're just
looking out like Oh his mom passed away
like maybe I could um just be there for
him but you don't put your life at risk
unless you're dating like you don't I
mean yeah and I just wanna say like it's
not even her life that she's putting at
risk it's the lives of other people who
are high-risk so she's a young in her
teen years but we're not here to shame
people for whatever it is but it was
just like a little shameful maybe I mean
it's only like not shameful if she was
going to where she needed to go to
quarantine with her man yeah with the
love of her life with the love of her
life I just couldn't I just can't see
Tyler see being the type of guy to be
someone's like fourth choice because
that's how it is like Hannah chose Jed
and then he didn't choose her and then
she chose Peter and he didn't really
want her oh no sorry then she chose
Tyler and then I didn't want her and
then she went to Peter and then she went
back to Peter and then according to
Hannah Anne who was being paparazzi
that's out of Craig's with Hannah Godwin
this weekend like we need to talk about
that I just I just don't see like Tyler
being okay like being this like third
runner-up yeah you don't just date ggod
than then become someone's runner-up
it's just not how life works unless it's
true love and true love Trump's all we
just need to talk about Hannah and
Hannah stepping out at Craigs calling
the paps on themselves in the middle of
a crisis yep had an ant's about the
weekend in LA with Hannah gee who
they've been like friendly on Instagram
for this whole season they were friends
before that's why Hannah and wound up on
the show is because she was a friend of
Hannah gee and Hannah gee made the call
God we're into Chris Harris and Hannah
Anna's when they're commenting on Hannah
G's Instagram like can't we move to LA
with you like she they're perfect for
each other and they were out and about
this weekend I'm making tic TOCs being
paparazzi at that side of Craig's which
you only go to Craig's like if you want
to get paparazzi and Hannah gee was
wearing a good American I'm denim
jumpsuit which we literally called on
the show that she would start modeling
for good American and it was just like
the thirstiness you love to say yes we
do love to see it not so much in these
national emergency time is slightly out
of touch but it's okay but it's still
really cute I mean the two of them they
could take on the world you know The
Bachelor is more mainstream and
prevalent and like accepted than ever
and I think that these two are gonna go
far
of course know they have the right the
right head on their shoulders and Hannah
is a perfect example of someone who like
went on the show totally selfishly like
she was a model she wet already had like
a hundred thousand Instagram followers
she's someone who went on the show
because she knew what it could do for
her but then she also played our cards
right and she's in a show based
relationship so no one really
she's that Thursday yeah you gotta do
both yeah it's it's a whole it's a whole
thing you got to work in it doesn't just
happen to anyone so many people go on
this show and they come out 50k maybe ya
know and they're not even know there are
people on the show who like literally
said okay didn't even change their lives
anything like they regret doing it yeah
so you got a and you gotta make it far
but not too far because then there are
people who made it like really really
far like Vanessa Grimaldi and then like
she's also irrelevant you know what I
mean but maybe just thought people
didn't like her like people didn't want
to follow her on Instagram people just
seen him relate her she she got to a
million followers and she literally is
lose his fault she's at like 700,000 I
just don't think that she was just quite
interesting to follow of course know
what I'm just saying like you you can
make it far and still not be relevant it
really is a parent formula you got to
make it far but you also need to play
the game it's like you can't just do one
thing when you need to be relevant you
need to get on tape talk like you need
to be story with other bachelor nation
people like maybe another bachelor
nation relationship then a breakup then
you date someone random then another
about maybe a celebrity like it's a
whole tit-for-tat and I think like it's
probably exhausting it's like you're
doing it for the rest of your life but
some people just wind up being not
interesting like Hannity like Lauren
Lane like Amanda Stanton right well I
think Amanda Stanton Becca Tilly Lauren
Lane like came up in The Bachelor
generation where people were just
genuinely interested in them they didn't
need to play a certain game like they
were just like the cream of the crop of
their individual seasons Ashley I like
and that just made them into celebrities
now it's like everyone wants to be the
cream of the crop so it's an actual
competition yeah not even just for
Peter's heart but for the Instagram
followers the cream always rises you
guys so true the creme de la creme like
there are some girls who will always and
forever be nothing of the sort
it's so true oh my god at the end of the
day that The Bachelor is a contestant
for the for the man's heart but it's
really like more of a weeding out
process for girls who are everything of
the sort and girls were not yes it's
like social Darwin and I'm for like who
can be an influencer so well said okay
you ready for our next story a little
more bachelor news because they're the
only ones who are breathing these know
you're the only ones were thirsty enough
so I can make news about themselves
we're in the middle of like a national
crisis international yes but also
speaking of Claire she is calling out
her ex Juan Pablo after he shades her
over the Bachelorette in this week's
segment of loser loser cried he tweeted
I just saw any time I say something
strong
it's cuz he used caps I just saw the
guys for Claire Crowley Bachelorette
season he also tagged her and it's gonna
be an interesting seeing her get hit on
by kids in their 20s I think this might
be the third season I'm gonna watch you
know what Juan Pablo is a loser like
what are you doing but I don't disagree
with his sentiment in the tweet it is
weird we mentioned on the show like
there's what is it 31 guys for Claire 20
of them are 10 years or more younger
than her there's only one who's older
than her he's not wrong
but like stop yes she tweeted back
jealous I just see it fascinating and
yet here you are older than 99% of them
and still can't practice compassion and
kindness see to me this is just like a
loser II answer for a loser II like the
clap that Queen I mean she just
responded to that like wandering within
the mindset of like what he news would
say about it when they wrote it up like
a woman standing up for herself like
this this is to me it's just a
definition of looser and looser crime
like his tweet was losery hers was even
more looser II these two people are so
irrelevant I mean I mean he's especially
irrelevant and I would have loved to see
her does not answer him like he's even
knew that he had a Twitter like I
totally agree to me like her not
answering is like it's why we why we
chose her it's like she's 38 she's
beyond the [ __ ] like she doesn't you
know to find herself by Juan Pablo she's
tried to find love on TV five times like
to me the hurt answering is like the
antithesis of the person we thought she
was right and it's like did you really
expect Juan Pablo to be practicing
compassion and kindness no it's like do
you know who you're talking to
yeah it was just really the whole thing
really smelled like these around those
are crimes especially because if she had
an answer like this wouldn't be a story
and she's in the news enough she doesn't
need the press and it's like now you're
putting his name in the news right next
to yours
agreed no there I totally agree this is
just so I just can't say it any other
way this is boo Zuri thank you thank you
there's no other way to say it no and
sometimes you just have to say what you
need to say sometimes there's only one
word for the job and let the words fall
out honestly I wanna see you be brave
Sara Bareilles is really like an
underrated songwriter yeah she's a true
talent true talent she took her talents
to Broadway recently yeah we trust the
musical good stuff katharine McPhee
yes she was in it too a lot of people
were yes so what some things oh yes it
was todrick and Carrie Carrie Russell
unclear but it said waitress jerk was in
it yeah waitress is a great social media
do I have your attention because they
got todrick and Miranda sings to be in
at the same time so it's like the
digital very cool Matt may very well
further I very much enjoyed it are you
ready for our next story it's a little
cute quarantine news I mean speaking of
ku speaking of cute quarantine news I
feel as though you know toasters are
working from home relying on technology
more than ever and there's so much that
they need to know when it comes to
working from home in a responsible and
effective way and sometimes relying on
laptop audio can lead to poor audio
experience and we know everything about
audio you guys it can result in
misunderstandings frustration even
stress or fatigue if you're working from
home you own a business you want to keep
your team functioning at a normal level
we're here to let you know about one of
Yamahas portable speaker phones that
should be a no-brainer for your work
from home kit I know everyone knows
Yamaha for their pianos their
motorcycles they used to have a Yamaha
keyboard growing up but yeah my husband
focused on audio for over 130 years
while their portable speaker phone is
discreet and a compact device that you
could throw in a bag take anywhere it's
packed with technology to make you sound
great on conference calls block out any
unnecessary background noise it even as
easy to mute buttons if Theo is barking
Ben is bothering me or sirens are going
off which is something we experienced
here a lot here at the morning toast you
can connect the software to zoom Skype
or Microsoft teams and you can even
listen to music or the morning toast in
between calls and meetings give yourself
in your team the right tools to
collaborate and keep your business on
track because Yamahas teams are fellow
toasters they were able to grab us a 10%
off code for all of their work from home
devices visit you see Yamaha comm /
toast for more information nets letters
you see Yamaha comm / toast thank you
you have a hot for that wonderful 10%
off code and making the quarantine live
just a little bit less stressful even
though do you think quarantine life is
more or less stressful than an average
day at work oh I think it's probably in
like less stressful because you're doing
less but I think the implications for
being in quarantine like I actually last
night I was getting really um stressed
out and just anxious about like what
could happen during this quarantine
because I watched um
Jhin on Saturday night and I I feel like
I've been able to anticipate like what's
gonna come next in this quarantine in
order to you know effectively prepare
prepare for the virus but and I'll talk
about it when we recap contagion but um
they there's a lot of like what happens
to society like after it's sort of the
rules are out of place and you know the
the army comes in and businesses are
closed and people start to like loot and
steal and break in and steal each other
it was like the society know the well
yes but the purge oh I never saw it me
neither but it's just like something
about crime so I just AM like anxious if
it never gets to that level yeah that's
really saddens good also I continue to
made me realize that like this disease
could be so much worse than it is like
in terms of the contagiousness and the
symptoms and like the death rate so as
much as it definitely gave me a lot of
anxiety it also made me realize like
okay it's not that bad it could be worse
it could be so much worse I also watch
pandemic which also taught me that it
could be so much worse yeah I'm just not
like imitating my brain with things like
that that are gonna make um I had watch
them cuz I wanted to get as much
information as possible and that's why I
watch pandemic cuz I was like maybe I
will learn something but it was funny
because they obviously finished filming
it like three months ago right before
the outbreak of adenovirus
except and it was like I want
information about what this virus is not
all the other 60,000 versions of viruses
that it could be yeah okay next a little
cute quarantine news I've been enjoying
following my favorite couple during
their quarantine Olivia culpo and
Christian McCaffrey enjoying social
distancing at home for those of you who
don't follow Olivia culpo one you should
and you should be watching her stories
because her her man and her sister are
holed up at home except they just got on
a private jet somewhere is in her house
at La yes and it's just so nice it's so
nice and it's so new and they're cooking
they're singing they're cleaning so
something like a really cute grand old
time and it's just cements that their
relationship is so real because you
cannot be quarantined with someone when
it's just a fling no this will really be
the test of many relationships you know
some people won't be made in quarantine
and some people will be broken in
quarantine and it's sad to say I think
this is one of the couples it's gonna be
made in quarantine so so so so happy for
them know that I am yes so I've been
enjoying their quarantine content
because it's also very responsible um
they did get on a PJ yesterday as I
mentioned I wonder where they're going
maybe to Rhode Island to her family
maybe we had been talking a lot about
like how private aviation
like what role is that playing because
there are so many travel bans but I just
never know if those things apply to like
rich people you know maybe let me try
charter see what happens I do think that
they do but I'm sure they're just
traveling within the country anyway but
I don't think that you can take or come
in on a private jet from a country that
now is under a travel ban got it okay
well I still haven't confirmed that but
I'm pretty Church I'm pretty I mean that
does sound right it would be weird if
like rich people could just like be
above the law above the law but you know
it wouldn't be the first time a lot of
celebrities are really committing to the
content when it comes to quarantining
themselves and I have to appreciate and
respect that um you know Chrissy Teigen
she like she's always like stepping and
[ __ ] on Twitter and she like cause a
major drama on Twitter this weekend I
saw a bit of it please recap I tried to
find like a story written on it but it's
clear that like the media is not giving
attention to dumb [ __ ] like this and I
saw it on a website called the blemish
and they're so rude like listen the name
like that Oh Chrissy Teigen whatever
what I do without you being on social
media probably get a real job so think
the Lord you exist what dumb ass thing
did Chrissy do today like such an
[ __ ] but it was only place I could
find this deleted tweet so she tweeted
this is not an ad but if you're holed up
at home or Durham or during America's
best food from Gold belly is the way to
go right now currently shipping clam
chowder from Boston Co bellies this
company where it's like you can order if
you live in LA and you want like a New
York piece of pizza they're like somehow
deliver like local stuff across the
country um we actually got like an apple
pie from them once it was really good
whatever I think I've heard of it yeah
it's like this new thing that everyone's
loving and someone responded Wow Chrissy
this is such a bargain for people holed
up at home with no sick pay and it's
like a hundred dollars for soup like
where whatever and and she was like wise
no but allowed to say [ __ ] to you guys
for [ __ ] sake just don't I just don't
get it I don't give a [ __ ] she ended up
deleting the Twitter because like people
were between because people were coming
for her being like you're so out of
touch like you really are encouraging
people are you ordered soup it's like on
June dollars um and I just really feel
for her because she's just always trying
to be like funny and relatable like
sometimes it falls flat and I hear that
and I respect the hustle um and people
are always coming for her but that was
like the quarantine cancellation drama
on Twitter this week I can't
wow you guys there's so much news and
we're still reaching hmm oh yeah no it's
it's just interesting to see like you
know the world's falling apart but we're
still read
we're going apart and people on Twitter
are still trying to cancel people like
we're nothing if not consistent yeah we
have to respect it consistency but it's
like our priorities are incredibly
[ __ ] up it's like we're just so
worried about what Chrissy Teigan is
eating and it's like you know you could
be dying yeah could be okay are you
ready for our next story because it's
it's a beautiful tale of a wedding that
took place this weekend
no most have been canceled we had a
wedding this weekend this weekend was
really the last weekend for weddings for
a few weeks yeah and I feel like this
was the actually the toughest weekend to
get married on because you really had to
make the decision like three days before
because it just got really bad it's all
I've known about this for a while
whereas if you're getting married in a
month we now know you probably should
cancel it but all the news came out this
week so this is like the worst weekend
you could have chosen to get married
yeah Brittany snow is married though she
weds Tyler Stan island in Malibu this
weekend the pictures are beautiful her
man have you seen him hottie oh my god
he looks like a hallmark like Prince
Charming hunk I love Brittany snow and
that's only been made even more clear to
me after rewatching hairspray this
weekend I was just like doing my hair
because I like felt ugly and I wanted to
watch TV but I also wanted to listen to
music so I decided on a musical and I
just chose hairspray because I saw it on
Netflix and because you just can't stop
the beat you that's a thing you
definitely cannot stop it and I really
got to thinking about hairspray how it
wasn't really taken seriously like when
it was when it came out but I now regard
it as like one of the greatest musical
like redos of all time like a lot of
people don't even know that hairspray
like the one with Amanda Bynes is not
the original yeah Nikki Blonsky was not
the original Tracy Turnblad and I was
watching and just really thinking like
whoever cast that movie is an absolute
genius James Marsden as corny Collins
brilliant Christopher Walken played the
dad John Travolta played the mom Jerry
Stiller was mr. pinky like Michelle
Pfeiffer was Amber's mom amber was
Britney snow that Amanda Bynes
Amanda Bynes exactly I found it Queen
Latifah I just kept thinking like no
this is like the most well cast movie of
all time it was brilliantly done and
they added songs and I usually hate when
like classic musicals add songs but the
songs they added were maybe some of my
favorite
without love life is like a job you
can't buy it with
love-life is like my mother on a diet
like a week that's only Sunday's only
ice cream no way like a week that's only
Monday's only ice cream never sent
literally just the best musical of all
time and I just wanted to give it the
proper credit like obviously I have a
lot of like fear anxiety and regret that
I wasn't the person who auditioned for
Tracy Turnblad because if you know
anything about Harris play the musical
it was an open casting call on Nikki
Blonsky was just a hairdresser in New
Jersey and she got the role and I just
think it could have been me I think I
was too yellow you were too young at
that time that you could have auditioned
for the recent um live rendition of
hairspray live but I'm glad that you
didn't have your name attached to that
no cuz it was trash but like I just I
love I thought Nikki Blonsky was
fantastic especially for a nobody but I
watch that film being like that should
have been me I know all the words to
Harris way like it's really in my range
um like I honestly like I have a lot of
sadness about that maybe one day they'll
do another one and like you as penny or
amber oh oh yeah I could really do both
yeah and then I was um I was dealing
with Beckett Oh with Becca Tobin and we
were like talking about how we like
would love to recast hairspray as like
with all podcasters because I was she
was like you'd be Tracy I would have to
be a merge a key movie penny
we're like who would be Link Larkin we
need like the like a male podcaster Joe
Rogan as corny Collins or something that
is so funny it's just such a good movie
and I don't want them to redo it because
I think the one we have now is perfect
but I personally would love to be a part
of the next one you know what's crazy is
the hairspray live the casting for the
new one was also an inspired casting but
for some reason I think because it was
live like and that's just too much
pressure to putting ourselves it didn't
hit but like dove Cameron as amber yeah
those live things like we're such a good
idea Grande is penny but then they got
hit with a curse oh because of rent and
then it's just they were never good it's
not a good idea though like I understand
that it's like exciting to do things
live but why don't we just do things
good yeah it's so true mean hairspray
good also that is my favorite one grease
live was incredible thanksgivin esse
Hudgens pulling out an incredible
performance the day after her father
died I just we have absolutely no choice
but to scan and julianne hough
everything on the sort everything of the
sort julian has taken a really
interesting turn in her career yeah and
I only have been able to follow it
because I follow Jack
on Instagram and she's pretty much like
a julianne hough update account um and
she's just become like a Tony Robbins
like Oprah and like in spiration I'll
speak her and it's really weird yeah
but I guess what else can you do like
she she went into acting I just don't
think like the acting world really
received her quite well she's a dancer
and I just didn't know like what you do
with that type of career she always had
an interesting career I think I really
like her I mean definitely that video
was a little crazy yeah I love all of
the movies that she's made though and
none of them have any justice safe-haven
Footloose she was incredible with miles
teller he was so good in that movie we
spoken a few times about how miles
teller is like gonna be one of the
greatest actors of our generation and he
really just started out like the way you
want the actor of your generation to
start out like Project X you know oh
that was that the the party Harty he was
just in like a million party movies and
then he like got really serious with JK
an awkward moment
JK Rowling Oki Simmons with the drum
movie like the best movie ever I just
made a bed and watch it oh no I made us
all watch it when we in Utah I just
think like you know if you want to be an
actor you should study um miles teller
it's like arc to the Oscars because he's
gonna win an Oscar one day and then he
was also in that awkward moment you know
yeah and that's just literally all we
can expect from a movie star get you a
guy who could do it all that's what I'm
saying well Brittany Snow is one of
those gals too I would say she's guy who
can do it all and have a wife as a
toaster I just heard the wife sorry
totally and now she is a married woman
who love her love her I'd love also like
the space she carved out for herself in
Hollywood it's like the go-to girl for
like a shout out say what how about to
say she was also yes she was very good
like she really carved out for herself
like whenever there's a movie about a
musical and they're looking for like a
shallow girl who can sing like she's
really carved out that role there's no
one else who could do it
yeah pitch perfect like she's always the
go-to I don't know when she was never in
glee ooh I think she must have just
missed vote also Glee was really a lot
of people who had never been enrolled
and she has been working for a really
long time yeah well what did she rise to
fame in like what do we know her from
her pitch part no we know her from
before picture that's what I'm saying I
feel like there was something was she so
good to like play like the [ __ ] Fred I
feel like she was an ice princess
under those hayden Panettiere such a
hayden Panettiere we're gonna get to the
bottom of this you guys because we
really have nothing else to do today and
neither do you except if you're working
from home and I feel like some people
working from home are like working
really hard but John Tucker Must Die Oh
John Tucker Must Die
got it yeah that was the big one she was
also in a lot of stuff before that but
like that's really you know that's what
really shot her man really she was in
Gossip Girl as Lily Rhodes and they
tried to like make that a whole thing
but yeah the young Lily van der Woodsen
and they tried to make like a spin-off
sort of from the 80s like the life of
Lily Rhodes and no one does this pan off
nobody asked for each one was Brittany
Snow in John Tucker Must Die she was the
girl who Tuck heard him oh right right
right and Jenny McCarthy was her mom oh
yeah
yeah I'm a car looks like an iconic
actress yeah Wow good stuff okay I'm
glad we I'm I'm glad we closed the loop
on that one too it feels good okay fifth
and final story a little crazy
coronavirus news that could maybe be
made into a movie one day except the
ending is like not that exciting
actually I guess it's the right ending
Tennessee man who's stockpiled
hand-sanitizer
donates 17700 bottles ahead of
investigation okay a Tennessee man who
went viral after stockpiling
17700 bottles of hand sanitizer don't
eat all the products Sunday after
Tennessee officials announced they would
investigate him for price gouging amid
the corona virus pandemic that has
infected more than 160,000 people
worldwide okay so a Tennessee man was
trying to profit ear off of the corona
virus he like went around his state and
last month and even some places in
Kentucky bought up all the hand sign
sanitizer that heat so that he could
resell it on Amazon at a higher price
and Amazon does not allow for price
gouging so they canceled his store he
was left in the ger in his garage with
like 18,000 bottles of hand sanitizer
and I guess they were gonna do an
investigation into his um you know
profiteering
but he's donating all the hand sanitizer
instead you know this is just a
beautiful and poetic story and really a
cautionary tale of don't be an [ __ ]
especially in you know times of need
let's take a quick break for the siren
well you wanna know something crazy
about this whole Purell feet fine ASCO
um that's a bachelor joke I haven't used
Purell once during this whole epidemic
and because I wash my hands with soap
and water I like do not [ __ ] with Purell
I never have but in Purell like you're
in a you know in someone's Lobby and
that dude you take it no because my
hands once I leave my house
they are like lava they only touch like
the things that I need to open things
they do not touch me until I get to the
next place and I wash my hands with soap
and water
I just don't [ __ ] with Purell maybe if I
was like at a place where I was do you
like multi stops and I wasn't in a place
where I could wash my hands I wouldn't
use pure out more um but I just I don't
I don't [ __ ] with it and I don't you
think I think that if you used soap and
water and like there was a there's like
obviously now an outage of Purell and
people are like what are we supposed to
do and it's like totally I am I've been
using Carell to actually clean my phone
I put like a little dot on the screen
and then take a tissue and rub it around
the front and back and if I'm just in a
place where Purell is I'll never just
pass up an opportunity Purell is like
it's like money so I'll never just not
take a squirt but I don't like stock up
on Purell like have it outside my house
because I agree there's it's a
replacement for soap and water so if you
have running water and soap and they're
not going to turn off the water anytime
soon like it should be a secondary yeah
like I have the Purell in my house that
I've always had I did not buy any Purell
for this and I feel like we can get by
without Purell I have to travel sizes
ones like just in case you know I'm not
going anywhere but in case I find myself
yeah if I were on a plane maybe I would
use Purell but I don't think people are
really going on planes right now no I
don't think they are either so unless
you're headed where I'm going to visit
your man in Jupiter Florida right of
course this guy's just an [ __ ] and
I'm so glad justice is being served this
is like if there's a you know a national
crisis and people's lives are being
affected in your first thought it's like
how can I profit off of this you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're a prick and I
hope that the CDC the FBI the CIA and I
ns come for you yeah but he did the
right thing so they go so they can back
down they can stand down and focus on
you know the other things going on I
guess but he was like forced to do the
right thing but I think it still counts
I guess ya know it's just it is what it
is um
so let's dive into our segment about
where we recap everything we watch this
okay let's go one for one like I want to
start and then I'll say you could start
but before if I may
just say one thing really quickly is
that okay sure should I get my toes out
of the way before you step on them that
would be just delightful of you um
today's episode is brought to you by
Charlotte Tilbury with 27 years in the
beauty industry
Charlotte beauty industry Charlotte has
been responsible for the creation of
countless iconic Beauty styles and she's
regarded as a visionary and trendsetter
in 2013 she changed the face of global
beauty with the launch of her makeup and
skincare collection decoding her
traditionally closed VIP expertise
giving women and men the tools to be the
most beautiful versions of themselves
she believes that everyone at every age
deserves to look and feel the most
beautiful version of themselves even if
you're being quarantined her client list
is extensive with celebrities Jennifer
Lopez Miranda Kerr Nicole Kidman Amal
Clooney she helped to find the glamorous
style for which she is recognized today
and her pillow talk collection is
somewhat of a big deal there on
everyone's lips it's the best-selling
globally adored new to pink shade that's
on everyone's lips it's the little black
dress and makeup versatile and dreamy
the perfect pink nude shade to bring out
the most beautiful version of you and as
of January 16th there are now more
pillow talk shades Charlotte is
expanding her iconic pillow talk
collection to include a medium and
intense shade of each pillow talk
product so there's now new shades of the
lip liner the lipstick the blusher and
the eye palette the iconic shade is now
available to flatter everyone's natural
beauty and can be also used to dial up
your look for every mood from day to
desk to date and beyond you know if
you're in a conference call sometimes it
helps to put on a little lipstick like
you'll feel a little bit more confident
you know willing to stand up to the man
get maybe get yourself a case of stick
it to the man the OSIS I love stick it
to men you know sis also I am wearing
pillow talk today in the shade intense
if you'd like to see what it looks like
on me Charlotte Tilbury is shoppable
directly from Charlotte Tilbury calm as
well as their freestanding beauty
wonderland at the Grove in LA
they're also sold at most North Durham
Nordstrom and Sephora's in North America
visit Charlotte Tilbury calm for the
store find her Wow sign on be glam okay
I made a list of all the things that I
watched this weekend and I will just go
an order of the order that I watched on
Friday night I went to dinner at
Olivia's because I was so nervous that I
wasn't gonna have any food and she
really stocked up on some meat she made
me a turkey Bolognese it was a [ __ ]
phenomenal and then we watched knives
out after I would love to hear your
thoughts because I loved it so everyone
loved it I've been meaning to see like
the project that launched Anna to arm us
you know into Ben Affleck's arms
and it was really really good I had two
major problems with it and I'm surprised
that more people weren't even talking
about the disgrace that was Daniel Craig
like literally ruining the movie he like
I mean I can't believe you would even
call that acting first of all his accent
was absolutely horrible he was he's
British and they're trying to make him
into like a southern private
investigator when he could have just
been a British private investigator like
makes no [ __ ] sense it was the worst
accent I'd ever seen he was such a bad
actor he made the movie into a joke and
I get that the movie had this like
satirical vibe to it where everyone was
like this exaggerated character but he
took it to a level that made the movie
horrible like I can't believe his acting
was in a movie that was nominated for an
Oscar like it was a disgrace towards
actors everywhere and it was disgraced
towards the southern accent I'm sorry it
was awful you know I don't disagree with
you I didn't feel the same way it didn't
strike me as odd but I do hear what
you're saying I also just think that you
really don't like Daniel Craig no you
know why I've always liked him but oh
you know what it is I'm sorry I know
what it is that play that yeah oh my god
okay when I was in NYU we had an
assignment I took like a theater class
don't ask who's like to fill a
requirement and one of the assignments
was like to see a play and like you
could see like a local play like a
student film but like obviously I went
to see like this fancy play everyone was
talking about with Daniel Craig and
Rachel wise called Oh betrayal or
something it was like about this couple
who like cheated on each other
sounds like a betrayal and I assumed it
was a musical because you just go to
Broadway like to see musicals and it was
not it was a play which is not a musical
I didn't know that and it was horrible
and I got yelled at by this woman for
eating my popcorn too loud and it was
just a terrible experience so maybe I
have a bad taste in my mouth about
Daniel Craig um because of that um but
I've just now seen him in two things
this week and he really like was a
disgrace both time so that cuz acting
was so bad it's like you know many
people would love to be on SNL and like
you do your whole opening monologue as a
pre-recorded music video like I just I
was really disappointed in this acting
abilities when he's regarded as like one
of the best actors in the world you know
yeah I just thought it was trash and I
argue with you my only other problem
with the movie was like the solution
like that where we found out who did it
like you know it was just to me it was
so not realistic like how Chris Evans or
Chris Pine whichever one he is Captain
America would like know that she was
gonna switch and then they were gonna
you know you know what I mean like I
just thought like the ending was a
little um like too convenient
yeah but I thought it was really like I
love so many of the characters and I
loved my house was too convenient at all
because at the end of the day the the
guy still did like needlessly die you
know which was so tragic so sad but I
mean like he just knew that they were
gonna tell the police like you know
anything that Chris Evans knew what
everyone was gonna do and I just didn't
think that he was that smart you know
yeah but he was a good movie and you
know what really like if I'm gonna spend
two hours watching like I hate feeling
like I that was a waste of time and it
wasn't but ya know Craig was really
close to ruining the movie and how great
was she who Anna Dharma's sensational
what a good actress crying and you
really fell for her like when you found
out that it was her you're like oh my
god oh you [ __ ] kidding me she had
that blood on her she I was like oh dumb
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] so it was a good
movie I would recommend if you're
quarantined definitely take the time to
watch it
yes okay so I mean III Capshaw's because
I did watch out on Friday night so today
um but then on Saturday night I watched
contagion because everyone is talking
about how it's literally the story of
coronavirus and I was just curious also
one with Paltrow woman yes it is and you
know what it's so misleading that it's
billed as the Gweneth Paltrow run
because spoiler alert she dies within
the first five minutes so dead yeah
literally dead um there are some like
flashbacks and stuff so we get to see
more of her but it's really the Matt
Damon one Matt Damon carries a movie on
his back okay Kate Winslet like starts
to carry it but then spoiler alert she
dies to God and like these people are
just dropping dead so on the one hand it
definitely caused a little panic and me
to realize like the scale at which these
things can happen but it also made me
feel a lot better to know that the
coronavirus is not that ya know because
that was the Commissioner of flu virus
that's a combination of something in
bats and pigs so it was like double
trouble
whereas Colonel iris is a version of
influenza that bats have passed on to us
and I did watch pandemic last night
which to teach me a good amount but
mostly it taught me that like there are
a lot of systems and teams and people in
place who go out and actively like
preempt these sorts of viruses and so
like it's not something that's so
unexpected like they expect that these
things will happen they try and get
ahead of it a lot of the time but um
this is just the way of the world what
wild animals carry diseases that are
passed down to livestock and then
through the way that we consume animals
and I think Joaquin Phoenix
speak he would be saying we should be
moving toward a plant-based diet is what
I got out of the show pandemic but
that's how they arrived in humans so
it's not so far-fetched but you know we
just gotta take the necessary
precautions so I think overall it's
definitely both of those things
contagion and pandemic combined made me
a little panicky mostly pandemic cuz
contagion was just a really good film
but it definitely shows you what can
happen if if things go awry but it also
shows you that coronavirus is not that
disease it's just so funny I think
there's like two people in this world
like you and me like people who want to
watch pandemic and contagion and people
who would literally rather watch
anything else you know yeah I just don't
want to be inundated like that that'll
like give me anxiety I'm I watched make
millions would you told me okay let's
recap um definitely too long you know
agreed when I was watching the first
episode I'm like oh my god literally
we're an hour and and all we did was
talk about this one first undercover
operation with the woman Amy I think
they did a great job of getting so many
people who were really really in it like
that woman Amy who still works at
McDonald's all the FBI agents the
prosecutor they got everyone they even
got Jerry Colombo's wife they got
everyone that was that was great that
and I enjoyed it too and in mind that it
was so long but then at the end I'm like
they're dragging this out and you see
that really no justice was served you
you feel bad for some of the people who
who participated because they were just
like I can't say if someone came up to
me was like doing a million dollars for
free like who I don't know what I would
say so and you see like Gloria she was
just a single mom you see Maria and
George George justice for them so you
they they got similar punishments to
[ __ ] Jerry like he got three years in
prison for a 12-year scheme but then
it's also like a victimless crime like
you know that 25 million dollars that
McDonald's gave away was gonna be given
to someone else so no but that's not why
it's a victimless crime it's not about
the money it's about like the people who
lost their jobs
Simon market yes the the printing
company brother we're because Jerry
broke everyone's trust all of these
companies had to go out of business and
those people lost their jobs it's not a
victim I'm Jerry deserves to still be in
prison today agreed didn't you feel as
you were watching it you were like they
were talking into August 2001 and it's
like 9/11 is about to I didn't even
realize oh my god I was thinking the
entire time I'm like and there is no
wonder that I've really never heard
about this story because nine
and happened like two weeks after the
roundup and that just trumps everything
in Jessup front-page news I did then I
just like this singing pin in my stomach
and I was like I wonder if 9 and then it
was approaching approaching I was like I
wonder if 9/11 affected this at all and
then of course like it affected it I
mean the star of the documentary was
obviously Doug Matthews he was so cute
and I do think that like you know while
on Undercover him and Amy totally had
sex cause like the way they were just
like talking about each other it was
like kind of cute like it was like the
one that got away
and it would just love like more on that
yeah I also loved that for the most part
all the people who worked at McDonald's
then still work at McDonald's and it
just shows that it's probably a great
place to work it definitely is there's
no doubt about that
the ending was really disappointing
because the whole documentary is this
arc where you get to the peak of like
look how many people's lives it
destroyed look how corrupt it was like
look and it was involved in you know mob
and then at the end it's like the
informant like Robin becomes best
friends with her mother-in-law who was
the informant who literally ratted out
all these people just to make sure that
Robin wouldn't get custody of her kid
and now they're all best friends Gloria
is still friends with Robin like it was
just all these people like literally
taking down other people like for their
own personal vengeance and then just
going back to being best friends yes but
ultimately like it had to end they would
have still been doing Monopoly
promotions and Jerry uncle Jerry would
have still been in charge of them if
someone hadn't come forward and he
stopped it and they still run and like
people's and even Gloria when she won
like she had to take a mortgage out on
her house to page area W ticket so her
bills became higher and she wasn't even
getting that much money annually from
the prize-winning when she got here she
was actually actually overall lost money
and like in order for less people to
like be victimized like her this thing
needed to end so I'm glad for the mother
yeah that airplane attended to like
thought she was the employment she was
dumb like to me she was the dumbest one
of all because she met someone at the
airport and just took a hundred thousand
dollars from them like all these other
people knew Jerry in some way like they
were friends family like but when that
guy I'm AJ the old guy from Florida
they were like would you do it all again
cuz he literally got like 12 months of
house or asked he was like yeah I wonder
why he said that because he literally
made over a million dollars he pays $100
a month
yeah his restitution and he got to make
he said at one point he was making six
hundred thousand dollars a year so we
got to do that I'm like no one was
aside from uncle Jerry like no one was
really making money from this because
the way that the payments come in like
they number two were the recruiters were
yeah Dennis I don't know I felt bad for
that guy Dennis but I mean was it a
storage what he did and justice for
Gloria and George Shaw subsiding this I
like when documentaries happened like
this because I think it does provide
justice for Gloria and George yeah
because I'm sure everyone in their town
was like ooh you were involved with the
McDonald's I know and then they watch
this and they're like oh they were more
of a victim than I was then the
documentary was really just the moral of
the story is there's no such thing as a
free million dollars like now there's
and then it makes you then it makes you
realize like let's say someone really
did come up to him was like no strings
attached here's you know million dollars
would you take it and you genuinely
didn't know that it was stolen oh yeah
so you can make it seem like oh these
people are done but like you never know
if you were in that position but you'll
do it when it's a McDonald's game piece
it's not even a million dollars you
don't know that it's someone at the top
that's stealing them you just saying oh
maybe someone found this and they're
giving it to chip at a casino someone
gave you like a five thousand dollar
chip you know I stole it yeah of course
so it's it's easy to cast judgment me to
pay me 50 percent of this thing you need
paid me a hundred thousand dollars of
Franny that's worth shady by let's talk
about Shahs of Sunset they moved to
Fridays and it was an explosive episode
kind of the episode we've been waiting
for when we had Reza and MJ here they
both told us both on air and off air
that like something happens that like
makes a friendship irreparable and we
couldn't understand what that could
possibly be and reso I am no longer
confused confused and Reza's on watch
repens live and in front of us he was so
apologetic like he's like I can't
believe that I said that but then he was
like posting on social media like really
I'm like not reflecting those initial
thoughts which made me was really
disappointing for me because this whole
fight between them is very it's a
problem for me because I'm a Reza and an
MJ Stan yeah but it's actually not I
agree I love them both but I'm actually
glad to feel so not conflicted because
it is so clear that Reza was in the
wrong like on so many different levels
and then the final knife in the coffin
was what he said about MJ having ten
abortions and that's why her uterus had
to be taken out turned child by her
uterus exploded yeah I mean everything
else before that I was pretty much on MJ
side because I just think a woman in the
hospital going through childbirth is
just not like no it's it's just even if
she wasn't in a woman
childbirth going through in the hospital
somebody made a claim about MJ someone
had their little monster who these
people don't trust and they just
automatically believed it nobody even
cross-referenced this allegation with MJ
if they come up to me like oh here's the
proof someone said this can you explain
and then it turned out that MJ was you
know the one starting all this drama
they never even got confirmation they
never even bothered to ask they just
heard of him alia Sheree they heard it
from destiny and then they just decided
that it was true yeah and it's like
thirty years of friendship and you don't
even give her the courtesy of asking
also thirty years of friendship and
you're gonna let some nonsense like that
trump your relationship and even asking
about someone who's in critical
condition in the ICU after giving birth
like sometimes [ __ ] like just
doesn't matter agree and by the way Adam
did you those things
see that's what no one is talking about
and that's where this show I'm still
gonna throw something out the TV why is
nobody really even addressing you're
talking about Adam literally responsible
for this whole thing like maybe don't be
disgusting and then people won't say
disgusting things right they don't cheat
on your man and if you are then like
resident no and arrested don't act like
oh those things aren't happening just be
like yeah and you know I know that he
did this at a time yeah like Reza is
like dying on this hill of defending his
man when his man is in defense I think
it might be the like he's obviously
making poor choices and using poor logic
because he's trying to defend Adam but I
just don't think Adam is anything of the
sort or worthy of that defense and I
just I'm worried about how it's gonna
end for Reza
yeah because Adams gonna be the thing
that takes Reza down yeah
Adams the worst he's the absolute worse
I like he makes me depressed being on TV
like they don't understand Michael Nessa
like loves him so much you have such a
weird friendship and now it's like
making Reza and GG best friends when
they've never been best friends
literally resin MJ have always had a
problem with GG so it's like now
everyone's just taking these alliances
like not because they think it's the
right thing to do but because they just
don't want to be like a lone on this
island
yeah but MJ doesn't give a [ __ ] and I
think it's because like she just is so
set in her personal life that it's like
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna deal with
this but then Reza's going and saying
that just meet it took it to a whole
other level and no matter what came
before what comes after like oh my god
because whether it's sure or not it
doesn't even matter because here's the
thing let's say we're it's true or it's
not true if it's true and this is your
friend of 30 years and you're gonna
spill her most personal secret just
because of one
fight on TV like what and if it's not
true and you're just putting allegations
out there about again your best friend
of 30 years and like you will get past
this fight but you can't get past things
that you say like that yep to me
whatever happens next is so irrelevant
everyone's like the video footage of
Tommy like going over and breaking a pot
like doesn't matter not a big deal at
least this is a pot and not his face
right and you know what let's say MJ was
responsible like she was the one who
stirred up all the drama irrelevant now
like what you said it's this is always
somehow like fights escalate some
someone takes it too far and whatever
whether they were right they were wrong
they were justified or not you are now
forever wrong and you owe the person an
apology and to me I didn't understand
before how a friendship could not
recover from someone saying something
and I was trying to imagine the worst
thing he could have said like I was
thinking like maybe he said like I hope
you died in the hospital like I couldn't
imagine what was so bad but this is
something I couldn't even fathom yeah
also you know what bothers me when like
a woman gives birth and then she shows
up at a social occasion and Adam is
though you know idiot who said this
who's like go be with your baby oh my
god
I can I she can't step out for two hours
that bothered me so much hanging out
with her friend I'm so lucky that was me
so much when people use that as like
some sort of Defense shouldn't you be
with your child
yeah like shouldn't you be playing naked
Genda with Django with Alia Sheree Adam
the child has a father
this was the father and like a nanny
like oh my god how dare you it's just
it's like the loser is lowest level of
insult you know if you're gonna insult
me I always say this like fine you've
got to be clever you got to be original
call me an irrelevant ugly like I want
them more creative like why don't you
good with your baby that's like when
people call me fat on Instagram it's
like duh like coming up something better
it's just that really bothers me and
then Reza started saying and it's like
right it was so you're more creative
than that he is more creative than that
I expect more from him yeah well you got
more and it was a disappointing episode
and I'm so glad Mike like all these
people they they refused to like say or
do the right thing they just like do
what they're like they're on sides so
you just take someone side because
they're your friend words like no why
don't you speak up and Mike is friends
with MJ and Mike was and I'm I just want
to see how this plays out like for real
yeah I think it's it's gonna be crazy
but that was really shocking like my jaw
was on the floor and I was really glad
that Mike was on the right side of
everything like and so his reaction
proportionate it was like what are you
doing oh it was so good like it was just
such a crazy episode and just like
Gigi's so dramatic MJ didn't do anything
to Gigi and Jesus I have to get out of
here yeah also we need to talk about
Sarah and our Kelly I literally have
never disliked someone so much I don't
like Sarah at all I think and I'm like
not even on team destiny and the whole
MJ fight but Sarah just like being so
mean about her brother like who [ __ ]
cares what is his middle school you made
that was me Ryder like you're both
adults like a bigger problem he's not
your friend so if it's your friend and
you're into her brother like you talk to
your friend about it but when it's just
so random or no you just make out with
her brother and then Russell's like a
[ __ ] started he was like so encouraging
of it when they were at top golf and
Bay's and then he's like did you talk to
Sarah
like who [ __ ] cares it's so not a big
deal and then like just Sarah things
Sarah it just has this like
condescending vibe better because she
has like an MBA and she's like so pretty
and and she just seems like no one's
good enough for her for her brother and
like that's how she feels about destiny
destiny is like this freewheeling like
free spirit and she just thinks like
Destiny's gross basically I'm just like
so over and I think as a society we're
so over like reality TV people coming on
and like judging their cast mates based
on nothing you know it's like her the
fact that she waits just openly except
Golnesa and then just be mean to destiny
so it's not like she's just overall like
a a standoffish person it says she's
just judging someone I don't know buddy
so much she's seen on TV and that's
[ __ ] NEMA oh my god but wait if we're
gonna judge people like based on things
like I just think we should all be very
judgmental and Sarah like she did date
our Kelly for a year and a half she did
I don't think we should be so I wasn't
planning on doing it out there you're
putting if we just turn around judgments
yeah interesting
yikes okay aneema is just the worst but
I like that he was like there for MJ
like I'm just I feel like so conflicted
about everyone like NEMA it's on the one
hand I want to be glad that he was there
for MJ be on the other hand he just like
wants to be so involved in like this
history and like yeah he's being you
know who he is he's being a Lydia the
friendship Whisperer on Real Housewives
of Orange County trying to bring back
Tamra and Vicki and it's like get the
[ __ ] out of my face ho like you don't
even know these people and not bringing
it for the reason that like you're their
friend you know salt I don't know
because I want to be relevant to the
storyline right and I want this show to
be good ya know Nima's the worst he's
the absolute worst I agree um okay I
watched two more things really quickly
Spencer confidential did you see
I've never heard of number one trending
on Netflix yesterday I like that they're
doing that top ten things I'd like to
see what people are watching it's this
new Mark Wahlberg movie about like
crooked cops and post Malone is in it
and the trailers like him in jail would
post Malone and you'd like oh let me get
in on this literary post Malone is in
the trailer and that's literally the
only scene that he's in it's the worst
movie ever it was so terrible uh I had
to put on subtitles because I literally
I'm like what are they saying and
there's this pivotal moment in the movie
where he's like who gave the message who
gave it and post one's like I'll give
you one word it's like the most
important I did you rewind I couldn't
hear the word he's at noon I'm like what
I'm a DC Undertaker mm-hmm Wonderland
was what he was saying like it was just
so poorly done I couldn't believe it was
number one they really they teased us
with post Malone who's number one cuz
everyone likes not the same thing that
you thought
post Malone the best part was his
girlfriend who took me six hours to
realize that it was iliza shlesinger she
did a great job I think this was her
first foray it's like serious acting and
even though the movie was a joke she did
a great job just not nothing of the sort
say save yourselves okay it was an hour
and 51 minutes it took us all day to
watch it do not watch it and then I
entered the day when Ben was at monopoly
with hunters everyone's been telling me
to watch it
Olivia specifically I watch the first
episode it was very very heavy it's
basically about like post-world War two
America had like certain Nazis like
snuck into the country and they're
pretending like they're not Nazis but
they're really trying to bring back the
fourth reich the first episode is really
sad like I actually was gonna stop after
that but it's very satirical and like
it's still like funny and sad it's very
very good it took me all day to realize
that the main guy is Al Pacino you know
he's really a chameleon of sorts believe
me it's Jimmy Hoffa Mike was even in the
Irishman I knew Al Pacino was in it and
it wasn't until after I watch the whole
movie when I went on IMDB did I realize
who he was playing yes to me I know Al
Pacino as Michael Corleone like young
handsome guy now he was Jimmy Hoffa they
look nothing alike and then he's also
Meyer Offerman um Olivia is like and how
good is Al Pacino I'm like when does he
come into the show I just I feel like I
didn't know who Al Pacino was until
after the Irish mix I think I assumed he
was like Joe Pesci I mean so I said
Olivia oh it's my cousin Vinnie cuz now
I'm thinking Meyer Offerman he just look
like my cousin
mini and he's like no no he's Jimmy
Hoffa I'm like excuse me no Jimmy Hoffa
like it's like tall and skinny and Meyer
Offerman is short fat you like it makes
literally no Jimmy Hoffa was tall you
know he looks just so Jewish like the
young and he meant to be Jewish yeah
yeah yeah and the main guy is this guy
logan lerman he's so handsome and it's
like his Graham I was a Holocaust
survivor and like I need to know if he's
Jewish like in real life he's so cute
he's probably not he's like Lerman maybe
I think maybe um but overall would you
recommend it cuz I've been seeing like
mixed reviews and I'm so not interested
I'm halfway through it's very Pitt
inducing but I really like it and I
really hate watching Holocaust stuff
because like it's just so painful but
it's still funny and like really well
done I really like it actually
um I'm not done with it though it's just
like they have so many like flashbacks
of the Holocaust I'm like like I was up
all night literally my whole dream of
being chased by Nazis like I think I'd
rather watch coronavirus stuff yeah it's
really Pitt inducing but it's like our
history and we have to remember yeah we
have to remember like but also we can't
possibly forget yeah age of like people
like genuinely believing that the
Holocaust didn't happen I'm glad that
shows are still being made like yeah it
did happen like my grandmother has a
tattoo on her arm like I I appreciate
that and I think it's my job as like a
good Gio to like participate and tell
the story a story well so that's what I
don't want to look it up because I'm not
done and I don't want to spoil it for
myself but ask Olivia I'm like is this
true cuz there's like this whole thing
about NASA and Olivia said she'll send
me some reading afterwards there were a
lot of Nazis like hiding in America
working for NASA like there is a lot of
it's really dramatized and they've
gotten in trouble for like
overdramatizing and like Auschwitz even
released a statement like that they made
up this hypothetical storyline about
something that happened in Auschwitz
they were playing human chess and I
watched that scene and I knew that it
wasn't real but to me like I'm not
bothered by the fact that it wasn't real
like there are so many stories of
terrible things that happened in
Auschwitz like they're just taking a
creative outlet like I I don't really
care I don't know I kind of agree with
what outwits is saying it's like taking
creative license and making things up
allows for like Holocaust deniers to be
like oh well that actually isn't that
didn't happen it makes you think other
things that people are talking about
didn't happen and also there were enough
like
atrocities committed during the
Holocaust that you don't need to like
use your imagination to come up with a
different one like yeah there's enough
material without how you having to make
stuff up and like open the door for
Holocaust deniers to be like oh that
didn't happen yeah but like I also just
can't live my life for the Holocaust
deniers you know that's true they just
can't let them define me and no we can't
let them define us but like we have to
be actively working against them I'm
also very curious about people who are
watching the show who aren't Jewish
because there's so much of the language
they speak like sometimes in like II
addition Hebrew and there's no subtitles
and I obviously know like I don't even
think to like for two seconds about it
but if you're not Jewish they don't do a
great job of explaining like there they
go to say mourners Kaddish like if you
don't have Jewish you don't know that is
like I just think like I'm curious if
the only people watching it are Jewish
oh that's interesting because I find it
so cringy like when TV tries to recreate
like a jewish booby and her chicken soup
that's so crazy from what i've seen like
this is cringy but it's not the worst
and they do they're pretty authentic
like to like the shools really look like
old Lower East Side shools
it's pretty it's pretty on the nose it's
a little cringy like some of the soup
stuff but I'm just curious people who
aren't Jewish like understand what's
going on half the time yeah but I think
that's like any show eventually you
figure it out yeah someone dies enough
times they say mourners enough times you
realize they're saying it okay mourners
they just conferring to his grandma as
his softe not never once saying soft
demyans grandmother no but like then i
think eventually you just start to
realize that maybe you think her name is
softer yeah that's interesting i caught
up on Riverdale mmm it is so good this
season because now the last episode was
it's not the end of the season but it's
the one that ties up the main storyline
and I'm just midseason finale no I don't
even think so I think there'll be an
episode this week even though suspension
production has been suspended because of
coronavirus and it's just been a really
good storyline and only I think if you
watch them match together because I
think a week tweak would be really
[ __ ] annoying but I think it's just
so good and I'm just like I stand so
hard for bug-head and barchi and like
just to see them there's like so many
cute scene love to see them thriving
love to see them thriving though I do
think things are gonna get crazy but if
you've ever been into a Riverdale and
wondering if you should like dip back in
like now is the time this season I think
it's season 3 right now that no we're in
season 4 um it's so good so she would
give our um our assignment yes we should
wait I also dig you watch curb no I'm
gonna my god it was so great yeah I
found out that this is the last season
No
yeah they're not two again anymore when
I was bringing it back again in a few
years I was really really looking
forward to an episode on coronavirus
like I was this whole time I've been
thinking like what is the curb episode
you know Larry is like a germaphobe he
opens Lotte Larry's in this episode and
there's Purell on every table so I I'm
like really I feel like literally
coronavirus will make them do one more
season like a whole season of
coronavirus yeah it's I've been looking
forward to it and Ben said that he said
it's the last one but maybe they'll
bring it back just like last time maybe
and also I've heard like the show is
really a lot of improv so it's really
just like a reality show at this really
um also I read a few books that I just
want to share with the class I finished
giver of stars by Jojo Moyes and I
wouldn't like highly recommend it
because I think people would be like why
do you making me read this because it
was kind of tough to get through but
ultimately I enjoyed it then I read the
wife between us which is like supposed
to be like gone girl style thriller and
it wasn't that thrilling but I rather
than a day so I guess it was pretty easy
to get through then last night I started
the two lives of lately Lydia bird and I
was actually gonna make Snitch pick it
for the redheads and she was like I'm
not picking anything you tell me to pick
no she's waiting for her why a moment
she is this is a like why it's by one of
her favorite authors um and I'm so glad
she she resisted because the book is
trashed and I can barely get through and
I think I'm actually gonna stop reading
it because there are so many things that
I actually want to read and I think if
you can't get into a book within like 50
pages it's time to step away and there's
no you know life is short even though
quarantine is long but there's there's
no time to be spent reading that's a
good name for today's episode of life is
short but quarantine is long yeah let's
give our toast would be of the week
assignment we've got a lot about this we
wanted it to be something like not silly
but not scary but thought-provoking
conversation provoking because we're
gonna need a lot of conversations to get
us through this quarantine so I we shot
this movie a while ago and we reference
it weirdly a lot on this show as rookies
your bases fine finest work except for
when he hosted the Golden Globes it's
called the invention of lying I do
believe it's on Netflix it's starring
Ricky Gervais and Jennifer Garner and
it's about the invention of line it's
not Netflix all movies that we're gonna
choose this week are on Netflix so that
you don't have to spend any money if
you're ready and efflux subscriber
yeah and we just want to make them easy
for you guys to watch as opposed to like
having to download like voodoo
yeah oh god I can't Vimeo it's a really
good movie I'm gonna be watch it cuz
haven't seen it in
and I think you guys are gonna like it
so make sure to watch it we're gonna
sign one every day so watch it today if
you have time working from home tonight
we'll recap it tomorrow and then
tomorrow we'll give another assignment
for the trust movie of the day so I
think it's hit wow I think that's it oh
wow it's in way over an hour you guys it
has been a pleasure thank you to
everyone who watched live to those of
you working from home make sure to
shower and try and have some delineation
between your sleep life and your work
life otherwise like it you'll go stir
crazy yeah to anyone who has been
affected by the current of iris and
their family or their loved ones we are
thinking of you and to all of our health
care workers we [ __ ] salute you and
to anyone whose job has been displaced
um
we're thinking of you we stand with you
if there's any way that we can help
please let us know we are just we'll get
through this together you guys we will
you didn't I'm a tease me at ease
soldier thank you thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast money
i morning show we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube we're also available as podcast
anywhere podcast we found so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher public video I
already cashbox all other places so ever
you listen to podcast find us the
morning tell us leave a five star view
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we love you guys so much we'll
see you tomorrow tomorrow